welcome to this blitz game again su
Shanghai
Oh 8 yes I've played this guy in new of
times now come on and I went to Castle
him played this guy a number of times
slightly slightly negative score yeah I
had this recently against him he played
the same stuff I mean really he was not
in any any it was it was ok for me if I
remember I remember correctly and wasn't
it
let me think about it takes
I was some sort of improvement but I
cannot really remember yeah okay it's
not a real real deal a real problem
because in this in this game that I had
I was I was perfectly fine um to e7 or
yeah I guess three seven I was perfectly
fine but I remember I had some sort of
improvement in mind
we did I really don't know what it was I
remember that I was okay anyway but
there was some way to improve upon the
upon the whole thing okay I'm thinking I
think this is how we played it in the
earlier game maybe
yeah not drooped you won because he did
something with f4 but we had something
like that okay
this is not so I can program I didn't
want to do this necessarily Bishop e8
but it's not a problem
the bishop is very very safely placed
and I can use my rooks on the open files
which is the most important thing that I
get it
get those into play easily I possibly
can go all night
a5 as well and ask the Queen about a
good square like where do you go 95
what are you doing whoopsy aid or what
or just trading more stuff
okay come on it said so that's a simple
method but yeah I saw that but I thought
that after the trade um I might even
have have a good position maybe I'm
wrong of course possible
whoopty one rupee 196 I guess this is
this is right yeah because the rook on D
one cannot enter on d7 now I can think
about things I can also go to b3 now
that that's not really doing any good I
thought that here maybe I can do
something with the pawn I mean I gather
that she will play b5 but he has rook a1
later yeah I see I see and well here we
will trade stuff I guess
okay so how do I play here
Bishop c6 that's probably the the
simplest solution okay I want and I want
the King in the center would be five
estranged this is just pudding I mean
what is this guy doing him
I mean why it has some leeway definitely
and until it gets really bad but not
sure why you want to misplace your pawns
here put them on dark squares and on
light squares and give me the
structurally again know what
okay I'm activating the King and see
what I can do here on to f6 and or
Bishop to e6 first probably
where do I put the night b67 f6 yeah
it's not so easy to enter the position
should I go g5 you might play just
reform and block the whole thing and I
still want to have them have the stuffy
on light squares maybe maybe a niche oh
if I go b6 it's very tough to to to make
any substantial progress in this
position well it's very difficult but
letting him mounts they're letting go to
see file is probably not good as well
I can go to f4 with the night
now the problem is it's very hard to
invade Yemen
it's very closed
maybe I can regroup putting the time
learning
yeah let's close this down maybe Bishop
back to the 7 and 926 try from there but
it will be will be difficult you know
now that sprits probably not possible to
do it and maybe it maybe I get this in
Jack tonigh tonight to e6 would be good
sure
check
so their way to win this not so easy
at least I don't think I can win really
I mean he played this very very strange
very strangely but yeah I don't know
maybe I couldn't win I mean despite all
the positional mistakes maybe I could
win and it's too close it's possible I
mean probably f-4s giving it giving it
away finally I wasn't really sure about
it all I was thinking that this
regrouping with the knight to deform
might might do the trick but Shaq it's
impossible that it's it's very very
problematic I can take a three here okay
this was the spot when he has totally
misplaced pieces so that I break through
him yeah the edge point is promoting him
yeah stuff like that might yeah I
couldn't read it well I was pretty
content that I thought I was getting the
noise and g4 wins okay and this okay you
know the I was thinking about this
briefly but I wasn't sure I had this
move him
this takes too long and I get this for
win yeah somewhere around there there
must have been a winner I mean it's it's
really a bit much if you completely
voluntarily misplace all your pawns but
it wasn't something forcing or
everything the this this is winning for
black it was it was simply weird that
that from here we are we are on and here
is an equal position and starting with
this is a mistake efore as a mistake and
so on after that I'm just playing for a
win and it's it's just a question of
precision I don't know maybe he's still
okay when he goes with before he has a
sword of fortress this kind of thing
where he covers those entry squares and
it's not easy to do to to make any any
progress is black it's really am yeah
it's really frustrating yeah I am I made
some progress but it's probably nothing
clear-cut he still has a somewhat yeah
fortress like defends him okay at the
end of draw thanks for watching